our next guest is the one and only Dolly
Parton she's considered as one of the
most iconic entertainers of our time I
would say all time with a career
spanning more than six decades She was
recently inducted into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame pardon has been nominated
for 53 Grammy Awards including two this
year winning 10 times and she's top the
country music charts with more than 100
hits she's also talented in the kitchen
sharing her love of baking with her fans
for with her fans through her
partnership with Duncan Hines Tony and I
recently spoke with her about four new
products including Buttermilk Biscuits
and Cornbread here's our conversation
with dolly
Dolly good morning thank you for being
here well good morning to you and thanks
for having me Dolly when this airs when
people will be hearing your voice you
will be 77 years old have just turned uh
what are your plans to celebrate
well actually I'm going to drop a new
song on my 77th birthday uh it's a song
that I think the world needs to hear
right now so I thought well I'd just
give the world a little gift it's a song
I kind of dreamed so I'm going to
celebrate that it's called don't make me
have to come down there it's like God
talking like don't make me have to come
down there my children you had best
beware I've let you try my patience is
all good fathers do but you're on my
last nerve I have had it up to here with
you so don't miss it
but it's all about God you know like
I've been like a father and all the
things that you hear let's talk about
your partnership with Duncan Hines it is
expanded cornbread brownies and biscuits
how do you pick these new recipes when I
started my work with them they wanted to
do some Southern recipes and so we
talked about it and we thought well
gotta have some biscuits gotta have some
sweet cornbreads you got to have that
those fudgy brownie mix so everybody
loves all that so we just kind of do
their research and I know kind of about
what southern people like you know food
is a form of love I love cooking for my
family philanthropy is also a form of
love and you recently got a grant from
Jeff Bezos and his foundation for a
hundred million dollars no strings
attached uh first of all what was it
like getting the news that you were
going to get that lump sum of money and
what can you tell us about what you want
to do with it
well mesos called me the third day that
I was going into the Hall of Fame so and
that was the day that the big lottery
was out for a couple billion dollars and
I bought a couple of tickets for that
and didn't get that one but that night I
felt like that I really you know had won
the lottery and so I'm I've kind of let
the dust settle while I think about what
I want to do with all that money but you
can believe that I'm going to put it to
good use and a lot of good things can be
done with that amount of money now you
were inducted into the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame and I think everybody
collectively we understood it's well
deserved but you didn't necessarily see
it like that initially you thought to
yourself that you weren't as deserving
why when they said they were going to
put me in I didn't know if I deserved it
I found out later that they base it on a
lot of things and I said if they should
put me in I would accept it gracefully
which I did and was very honored and
proud but because I got something I
wasn't sure of I thought well if I'm
going to be putting up Coral Hall of
Fame I'm going to have to earn that
title so I immediately started work on a
rock and roll album it's going to come
out early fall Dolly there is a script
floating around that was about your life
a biopic Dolly and it was it was called
one of the best unproduced scripts last
year now if this does get done our son
say when it gets done a movie about your
life who would you want to play Dolly
Parton
well I don't know I think when it gets
to that point we'll be auditioning a lot
of different people and we'll just have
to see what does this actress need to
possess what does she need to come with
who does she need to embody when acting
like you
well she would need to have my spirit I
would think and my personality she'd
have to have a lot of that fire and
spunk and she'd have to have some boobs
of course whether they were homemade or
whether they were for real she'd have to
look the part she'd have to be a little
bit over-exaggerated but uh hopefully
that wouldn't be that would be pretty
easy even a boy could do that
well I hope this I hope this biopic gets
made I really do uh you know you you
connect with generation after generation
of fans I am curious young people who
may be seeing you right now for the very
first time what would you want those
young fans to know about your life until
now what's the most important thing for
them to know I would have them know that
if you have a dream and a passion you
need to be true to yourself and true to
that desire that you have and just go
for it and work without fear I've always
said that my desire is greater than my
fear and that's where a lot of people
get crippled and never really get never
really get going because they're afraid
to even try but if you don't try you're
never going to know so just do what you
feel is right in your own heart and in
your own mind
um all right well Dolly uh your music is
going to live forever uh and last
forever but this plate of food right
here is not and I'm gonna tuck in no you
want to take us off here are you gonna
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and just grab me
a few of these thank you so much dolly
um yeah I thought it was awesome yeah it
was great and that was not just like
chatter for TV at the end we ate I had
two brownies yeah delicious cornbread
dangerous good to me she's not slowing
down at all dollies Duncan Hines
products are rolling out right now and
you can hear more of the conversation
with Dolly Parton on our CBS mornings on
the go podcast you know some stuff gets
left on The Cutting Room floor you can
get it it's available at your favorite
podcast app just go ahead and check it
out and type us in